hello everyone my name is Karen Morton
with Phil purge the radio show i'm here
with Brooke Lewis actress producer and
she was generous enough to to spend 50
minutes with us in the studio and she
also brought us some wonderful treats
from starbucks so we just want to thank
her by presenting her a snork tea and
this is actually my favorite storm tea
and I thought that Brooke would like
this so Brooke here you go I love it let
me stay wait I gotta look at first guys
hold on oh so those strangers have the
best candy I love it's a little scary
it's a little harder ask you guys I'm
loving it thank you so much Karen thank
you David this rocks
you